thank you
[Music]
welcome to another great episode of
careful boys today we have a very
special guest we have Mr Hunt's kids
ah I'm just kidding all right let's go
it's a great first impression
dude yeah we've seen you killing it on
kill Tony and you're opening for Rogan
now yeah holy crap man it's pretty crazy
you were you were just uh you're you
were a regular and kill Tony for a while
but then before that were you just a
random walk up and you get a minute to
make them laugh totally uh American
success story The American Dream you
know just from the bucket to the private
jet yeah dude so if you guys you guys
watch kill Tony yeah that's where I
found them first and then like I saw his
stand up there and his deliveries just
so different from everybody else yeah
and also like he's just getting railed
on by Tony and then he's just taking
it's just funny he can hang it's funny
yeah but he's yeah giving dishing it
back but his delivery's all always
consistent and so I hit him up and I was
like dude you're [ __ ] hilarious man
so I was like you gotta come to JK we
gotta have you here hey who hit you up
first Joe or Bart uh uh I don't remember
I think you did oh buddy responded to
Bart that's why he's here oh he
responded to me too but I think in the
at that time it was you you were
probably I remember we were at Vegas at
the same time and you just did the
opener for Rogan the museum Grand yeah
and then you're like oh yeah I'm not in
La yet so then after that I went off to
Hawaii we stopped chatting yeah yeah the
LA thing like once I'm here like I've
been doing a lot of stuff so that's like
good because everything's here
especially the Asian stuff
have you noticed anything particularly
different in terms of what the Asian
stuff
it's more high octane this is like the
peak the cream of the crop of the Asians
any other Asian shows or other Asian
shows you know
um I don't is there a competition but
yeah I mean I don't want to we're
competing publicity
no just kidding I'm doing a dumbfounded
yeah we don't mention his [ __ ] name
sorry what else are you doing have you
done have you done celebration no how
about Invasion no yeah yeah you never
did those I did celebration yeah Asian
persuasion 2022 ah dude all the college
shows they named their they think
they're so unique but every [ __ ] year
they name their College event the Asian
Club gets together they're like what
should we call it oh I know what it is
it's age Invasion money yeah celebration
yeah preparation celebration is pretty
good celebration right yeah I like that
one yeah those are good so I feel like
you've probably seen a lot of different
Asian communities being that you started
in let's say Jersey is where you were
born yeah Brunswick and then you went
with Seattle from there yeah and then to
uh New York yeah oh but you went to
school in Georgia Atlanta yeah Atlanta
okay yeah you know and then what's this
blood type Ryan we're gonna tell your
story yeah and then you wanted to be you
want to get into haircuts but then
you're like nah I want to do comedies
what do I want to do next and then when
did you get Korean
Korea the whole time so then when you
traveled around that much did you do you
feel like you saw it was that anything
to do with like were you part of
different Asian communities at all were
you just kind of doing whatever I
usually did the church thing with my
parents so oh okay I got to know the
Asian community that way and that's fun
that's cool you know but you can't have
sex with anyone there yeah yeah bummer
yeah I would argue that the most sex
comes from church
I know I'm not but they don't always
look the best
I like church girls
well you probably went to a church with
cool looking girls I didn't go to church
that's why stacked Church girls because
then it's like whatever they're wearing
you can see what's going on yeah it's
exciting Sunday dresses that's good
where do you reside now Austin Texas
home of the
Freedom Fighters did you decide to go
there to do comedies yeah kill Tony and
then I became a regular I was living the
aim was killed Tony yeah oh wow that's
cool so you moved there to do kill Tony
you're like [ __ ] I'm gonna do it yeah
and it worked out it was crazy yeah you
said you're living in a van yeah I was
living in a van and I was like I'm just
gonna go to Austin check it out and then
get out of there before the summer hits
but then I got it and I was like [ __ ] I
have to live in a van in Texas just to
do kill Tony what was that like how long
were you able to live in it it's like
waking up in a sauna but some people
they they glamorize that [ __ ] like I'm a
van influencer yeah I'm living the van
life but for you it was more like I'm
poor yeah it's practical this is like
you know like it's a Tommy mat it's like
very Asian very like Marie condo yeah
it's interesting how people always want
to talk to people who used to live in
bands but not who currently live in Vans
that's sad yeah it's too unrelatable
past tense thing yeah when you were
moving all those times your family was
not coming with you to all these things
no yeah they were just chilling being
Asian somewhere did they uh also Asian
you and be like oh you won't be a doctor
no they were just glad I wasn't in jail
or like doing drugs on a homeless oh
that's good but you did complete
mechanical engineering yeah I have a
degree Bachelor of Science I'm very bad
at it don't have me build any Bridges
it'll fall down really yeah have you
tried Bridge simulator yeah oh yeah yeah
there's a bridge simulator yeah [ __ ]
yeah it's on Steam dude check it out
sick yeah that's awesome
did you want to invent [ __ ] or something
with mechanical engineer to not be a
loser I just want to make a lot of money
and have like a normal office job what
happened what transitioned you from in
that path to becoming loser I just
didn't see the larger picture like why
am I Building Bridges for these [ __ ] I
don't even have health care yeah oh they
don't give you health care I thought
those kind of companies are loaded well
yeah they do but I wasn't I have to like
you know get through not as an intern
yeah so when were you aspire to be a
clown
um when I failed at mechanical
engineering and uh yeah and we're all
clowns here yeah but you've got a
Bachelor's over there yeah you didn't
fail why do you say you failed I mean I
failed uh in the job like the job I
wasn't really happy with me and also
like I didn't get good grades so it's
hard to get a job oh they look at your
grades yeah you gotta have good grades
too but do you feel like you were ever
like really in it though like your heart
was really in it no you couldn't give a
[ __ ] probably just going through the
mood it was just school to me you know
like I don't like school if I'm like a
kid and I'm like man I want to be you
know I don't want to I don't know what I
want to do yet sell me on mechanical
engineer
well you'll be having stability you'll
have like a you know mediocre life
you'll have Safety and Security and you
can be like a little like a cow like
cattle
sounds great I love cows
salesman kind of hit so what what where
did this comedy like from mechanical
engineering to like stand-up comedian
where did that happen like yeah I mean
it's all I know it's all engineering
jokes no it's all Joe Rogan honestly
you're inspired by him yes yeah oh wow
like this is the meritocracy this is
like fun this is individualistic I don't
have to rely on some [ __ ] so let me
if if you can charge people at the door
to come watch your show then you can
make money just seemed like a good so
that must be mind-blowing that this guy
inspired you to actually pursue comedy
and then you end up opening for him yeah
wow that's cool come true like I've been
watching him from afar molding my life
based on what he says and then he's like
you did well you have become the thing I
wanted you to become now open for me
that's so Chic dude get like along the
way did you ever get any other
affirmations from like just people in
your life or friends that were like hey
you're really funny man you should do
this like yeah I mean I got affirmation
when I was doing it like I wasn't
failing at it yeah I was doing well in
Seattle and then I went to New York and
I kind of struggled for three years but
people still told me I was funny I still
felt good and uh you can't deny what you
feel in the room so every day in stand
up you get access to an audience so I
just feel myself with that you know when
you say struggling in New York what what
do you mean by that they weren't [ __ ]
with me they weren't booking me on stuff
they were just like whatever we don't
need you but I was just doing the open
mic you can't stop people from doing
open mics
um so I just kept doing that
unfortunately
one thing about it I think the cool
thing about uh seeing Hans on kill Tony
is that you're a lot of your comedy
comes from your natural responses to
somebody talking like it's not all just
like one man one mic kind of thing but I
feel like that's you really shine just
answering someone's question like
plainly yeah do you do crowd work yeah
sometimes uh usually when they shout out
something I don't like to do it unless I
have to because then it doesn't feel
like I'm doing it honestly I'm just like
what do you do for work where are you
from then it's like I could be doing
this about anyone but some people are
really good at that which is fine but
yeah I like to like do it honestly and
like Oh shut the [ __ ] up or something
because then if the audience wants them
to shut up then it's like easier to tell
them to shut up and everyone goes yay
yeah but you gotta get the audience on
your side I feel like he like he's
special because his [ __ ] crowd work
like when they asked you oh Tony asked
you uh what your top three hated racism
and he had all good answers
because like it's not like there's
committees that are funny and then
there's some that can [ __ ] will just
like melt down under kill Tony like
there's not built for that sometimes
it's rough to watch so as soon as I
can't watch it but then his shit's like
it's he's like standing up to it but
it's not like it's not hitting back it's
just like you're [ __ ] Tai chiangle
it's the Asian way you know Asian
conversation style like oh yes I agree
with you yeah exactly and make it
completely different
yes
you want to know the top three you don't
have to do the bit because we we know
you did that it doesn't translate it was
like more in the moment but yeah it just
sounds so bad
Native Americans and African Americans
oh I think I seen that one
it's like they were just straight up
asking basket and he just like was
answering that's what's so amazing about
it like what would most people even say
in that situation Sri Lankans don't get
much hate so I'd say go for it yeah they
give you some shine yeah a lot of people
don't know that they exist so the fact
that that I know that they are there is
like you know positive that's awareness
right by India yeah it's an island M.I.A
one of the most corrupt places on the
Earth
Sri Lanka yeah it is pretty it's ran by
just nepotism and family well isn't that
the family that ditched it too yeah oh
there's conversation but yeah bad
whoa but you're right it definitely
doesn't work in the room
well yeah most [ __ ] asking after the
fact isn't gonna definitely should have
been there definitely felt weird after
you said it yeah that's what's funny
about kill Tony material out of context
is always weird let's just try one more
let's just see if it's weird one more
time unique show too that's a different
different room well the format's what
you do a minute and then he just roasts
you for like 30 minutes how does it oh
it's just like him asking questions like
why did you say that where are you from
let's find out what something
interesting you could have talked about
is
and then they find out more about you
and then it's like yeah you should have
talked about this instead of like your
random observation about butterflies or
birds and pigeons so is it like you're
getting critiqued like you prep material
and then
Comics critique you yeah oh yeah yeah I
love it but I just didn't get the format
because I was like is it are these guys
just roasting each other all day or are
they critic like are they really like
helping you develop material or like
yeah it's a little bit of both oh cool
yeah it's really about the show they
want to have a good show and then
helping you is like well if we get
around to it yeah where do you want to
go with with all this like obviously
you're doing stand-up already so like
but are you the guy who's like I want to
do the sitcom thing are you the guys
like I want to do like the FX show I
would like to I would like to just like
do comedy over and over again just
headlining do an hour in front of
different places and just get really
good at talking to people and you know
getting good at the art of comedy and
making a positive time in a room full of
people I think that's I I just wanted to
stand up but if I can do other things
you know I'd love to do sketches and TV
shows if it's easy but if it gets in the
way of the comedy then no all right nice
so you just love stand up and then so
for like comedic acting and all that
that's more like on a as a fun side
thing if it if the opportunity comes
through it'd be disrespectful for me to
be like I'm an actor you know like I
spent no time doing it it's like a
comedic actor being like I'm want to be
a stand-up it's like you're not a
stand-up yet yeah so I respect the art
form too much to do it I'm too you know
like yes no I I feel like I wouldn't be
the best at it like I would be like a
good like autistic character Maybe
that's good news Kevin James's acting
career offensive to you like offensive
to acting you think it's offensive to my
bank account get jealous she spend so
much money on it
buying so many boxes you always go see
the movie yeah he drops yeah yeah the
zookeeper
do you uh are you friends with Jason
Cheney no I don't think so I met him
recently at The Comedy Store dang he
said you guys are friends oh [ __ ] I
didn't say that [ __ ]
he comes he comes here often I just saw
that he like imposed with you guys
together I was like oh that's cool yeah
I just met him yeah super nice he's cool
dude yeah nice is a good word for him
yeah yeah hey can you explain your shirt
I like your shirt uh it was actually at
the MGM Grand uh right after I did the
set and Joe was getting off stage
someone threw this shirt at Joe
[Laughter]
my whole career
is left over yeah
now here but the successful part is his
leftovers is still probably millions and
[ __ ] like it's still extremely sweet
I know so how many times did you do to
kill Tony as a regular before that
happened uh well I did my first arena in
March and I became a regular in May
um but I was opening up for Joe and the
Vulcan for like six months before that
so it took about six months for me to
start doing it at the Vulcan in Austin
how did that conversation happen like
did he see on kill Tony first or did you
guys know each other separately and he's
like you called me up Tony was like hey
come on Joe wants to have you as opener
yeah I was like oh I have a show it's
like [ __ ] that show don't do this but I
have an obligation I said I would
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] the local scene
no just kidding
is it are people like trying to use you
to get to Rogan now yeah unsuccessful I
don't even have it you know you use Tony
to communicate you don't even direct
line
like a Chinese Whisperer that's so funny
that must get so old hearing that oh
dude that's what I'm saying by Eddie
Bravo yeah so you don't like it when
people ask you to get to Rogan no
because Nick was about to ask
[Music]
your face was on the Strip right with
Rogan in them because I I remember
during that time
when you guys were doing MGM I was
driving around and I was like oh [ __ ]
I think I think the sign had you guys
yeah I didn't see it I didn't see it
um yeah I'm glad that's a badass
response to that dude yeah I [ __ ] see
it I was probably too busy he's like my
face was on yeah
no [ __ ] idea this has been on a lot
of strips was that like your biggest
show after like your audience yeah
yeah audience wise I mean they were all
big they're all equal like I did the MGM
Grand I did the London O2 Arena I did
um the you know the Schottenstein Center
I did the five star Arena so they're all
amazing
how long is your uh opener set 15
minutes oh wow damn what's the longest
you've done so far like an hour
you did 50 minutes last night nice doing
it in Oxnard oh yeah tonight yeah
Oxnard it'll be a nice drive one time oh
yeah it's a big comedy stuff yeah yeah
did um would you say that your sense of
humor at least parts of it are innate
were like does your family have the same
kind of humor you do yeah it's like
they're quiet like well [ __ ] this this
is stupid and they just have quiet
bangers that just kind of come out every
now and then yeah that's kind of my
thing I'm not like a large like
personality I'm just more like yeah why
would you be a large personality I'm
just gonna make fun of large
personalities yeah
that's a good way to do it there's not I
don't think there's a lot of people with
that comedy Niche you know right sit in
the pocket yeah like your style that's
why I like his delivery yeah because
everyone's everyone's [ __ ] loud yeah
and then he comes in and he stands out
because he's the same volume and tone no
matter what he's saying yeah exactly I'm
the cool people listen more yeah
what was he saying yeah
they're more engaged
the quiet guy is saying something let's
hope it's not about how he's going to
murder us I also like how I don't know
if it's like a real effect but it sounds
less offensive when you say things the
way you do yeah it's like sweet you
could probably say a lot of things I'll
be like yeah this guy has a point like
when you watch his stuff transcribed you
just like good Lord but like if it's him
it's like oh yeah I could see that I
feel safe around him you know yeah it's
Sri Lanka yeah yeah you're right I think
he could read Kanye and be like yeah
yeah yeah
we're gonna talk about that yeah that's
all Kanye needs is like a more chill
tone of voice yeah you sound too angry
about her yeah is that anxious
yeah making it too real it's true though
dude if Kanye did it while he was
playing with toys I think he could get
away with it if he's playing with
actions like Soul voice when he says the
the Jewish media yeah yeah if you think
it's not so mad if you said like the
Jewish media yeah as opposed to like the
[ __ ] Jewish meme
but yeah it's cool to congrats on
everything though in general it's really
awesome to see that rock it up like that
thank you it's been amazing I've been
super blessed have you upgraded your van
at all yeah I have a house
that's an upgrade in Austin yeah but no
AC yeah yeah still keeping it real
this still showering and a Planet
Fitness
[Music]
foreign